in a rare public reversal president
Trump says the US will allow migrant
families to stay together even with his
zero tolerance border policy still in
place the President signed an executive
order temporarily ending the separation
of children from their parents who
crossed the border illegally the
president exercised power that he
insisted just last week that he did not
have he changed his mind on her intense
pressure from the public loyal
supporters and even members of his own
family
huija jiang is at the White House where
many questions remain unanswered weisia
good morning good morning Nora sources
tell CBS News that public remarks made
by senior Republicans played a role in
the reversal and president Trump said
First Lady Melania Trump and his
daughter Ivanka also lobbied him to
change his mind
we're gonna keep families together but
the border is going to be just as tough
President Trump played to his base
Wednesday night in Minnesota Democrats
put illegal immigrants before they put
American citizens what the hell is going
on emphasizing border security over
reuniting families we want people to
come in through merit earlier President
Trump weighed his immigration policy is
strong and you don't have any heart
that's a tough dilemma
perhaps I'd rather be strong and later
backed down from part of his key
immigration policy after mounting
pressure I didn't like the sight or the
feeling of families being separated
Ivanka feels very strongly my wife feels
very strongly about it I feel very
strongly about it the reverse though
follows days of defiance when you
prosecute the parents for coming in
illegally what should happen you have to
take the children away and insistence
that the only solution was a legislative
fix the Democrats forced that law upon
our nation but the executive order is a
temporary solution allowing families to
be held together for only twenty days it
also does not address what happens to
the more than 2,300 children who have
already been separated from their
parents
the administration put the pressure back
on lawmakers today to work with Congress
to get the fix a lot of things that need
to be done can only be done by Congress
on Capitol Hill Republican lawmakers
expressed concern that this is not a
permanent fix so the president's
executive order is going to run into
challenges we still need to fix this in
Congress initially a Health and Human
Services official told me there would be
no special efforts to reunite the
families but late last night
HHS walked that back and said that
spokesman misspoke adding they're still
waiting for further guidance and Border
Patrol says the kids won't be free
tonight
prosecutors avail there is some
confusion yeah it's a very confusing and
so heartbreaking situation that picture
sort of says it all behind me